[MUSIC PLAYING]
AJA HAMMERLY: Welcome
to the live Q&A.
I'm Aja Hammerly from the
developer relations team.
In today's Q&A,
we'll be focusing on
questions related
to Urs's keynote,
"Hidden Forces, What's
Next in Enterprise IT?"
If you haven't had a chance
to watch it yet, that's fine.
Urs will give us a
60-second recap shortly,
and then you can watch
the whole thing later.
And if you have a burning
question that you really
want me to ask Urs,
there's still time.
You need to make sure
you're registered and logged
in on the Next On Air website,
and then click on the Open Q&A
button, which is directly
below this video.
And now, coming to
us live from Zurich,
I'd like to introduce
Urs Holzle, Google's SVP
of technical infrastructure.
URS HOLZLE: Hi, Aja.
Hi, everyone.
Yes, I'm Urs Holzle,
and I'm responsible
for the technical
infrastructure at Google.
That's all the way from the
hardware and the data centers
and the networks, up to the
software in the cloud platform
itself.
And in case you missed it
this morning, in my keynote,
I talked about two
key things for cloud
and for the enterprise.
First, that
enterprise innovation
can catch up to the rate
of consumer innovation,
but only if the
enterprise adopts
a always up-to-date
software stack that
works across any cloud, and on
premise, of course, and edge.
And second, that Anthos
is exactly this stack,
and that it will play a
role similar to what Linux
played 20 years or so ago.
So Anthos is as safe and as
clear a choice as back then
was choosing Linux, because
it runs everywhere, it's based
on open source and Kubernetes.
Because it's based
on Kubernetes,
everything will
run on top of that.
And so that makes an
Anthos a safe choice
for the next decade or two,
because when you choose it,
you don't really give up
any other choices, just
like when you choose Linux.
So that, in a nutshell, was what
I talked about this morning.
And I'm looking forward to
answering your questions
either on that, or pretty
much anything else.
So with that, back to you, Aja.
AJA HAMMERLY: Thanks
for the recap.
I'm sure that a lot of
people haven't had a chance
to watch the whole video yet.
And so I'm interested, and
I'll make sure that people
I know watch it later.
So, first question.
This one's from our
developer community.
And the question is, what
can managers and leaders
do to help their teams adopt
modern development workflows
and tools?
I know that this is a question
we get a lot as advocates when
we're out in the field.
People want to know,
where do I start?
What can I do?
How do I make this
move for my team?
URS HOLZLE: Great question.
And actually, much easier
asked than answered.
So there's no magic
bullet in the end.
I think the key, I
would say, is to try
to learn from someone else.
And in a way, that's what
we're trying to do with Anthos.
So you can look at Anthos
as a technology stack,
but it's just as much a
set of practices that have
proven to work well over time.
And so when you
use Anthos, you're
really introduced
to those techniques,
be that about the
development self,
or how you push,
do gradual pushes,
or actually, how you
operate or how you secure.
So I think the key
thing is that you
want to pick something where
actually, the workflow itself
is opinionated, someone's
actually thought about it,
and where you buy not just
a piece of technology,
or you don't just use
a number of tools,
but you really use it together
in sort of an end to end way,
and you try to
learn from the best.
There's a ton of content
on YouTube and so on,
and there's a ton of content
on our developer websites.
And that's actually what Aja
and her team are great for.
AJA HAMMERLY: Oh, I'm
glad you think so.
So you're saying that Anthos
is both technology and best
practices that have been
tried and true by people
who've done this a lot,
like Google, but others.
And one of those best practices
that I've heard a lot about
is multi-cloud.
It's one of the main
things that people
are excited about that
I talk to with Anthos,
although there's lots of
cool things in Anthos.
Can you talk a bit
about multi-cloud?
Like, what are some of the
trade-offs versus benefits
of going with a multi cloud
strategy versus a single cloud
strategy?
I know this is something
a lot of bigger companies
are thinking about right now.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah,
I think, actually
that is a much easier question,
because the whole premise--
like, the trade-off
usually comes in two forms.
One, it says, well, the upside
of multi cloud obviously
is that if you pick something,
are you really going
to be sure that for
the next 20 years,
this is the right vendor to pick
until you want to have options.
And, also, you want to
use the best of any world
and move at your own pace,
leave some things on premise
because right now you
don't want to deal with it.
Move them at your own time.
But then the downside, or
the portrayed downside,
is that, well, let's say,
if you use three clouds,
you actually need to train
your team three times.
And you do security in
three different ways.
And you do all kinds of
things three different ways.
Plus, if you want to
be common between them,
you're really dumbing
down what your cloud is.
And you're sort of giving up
most of the advantage of cloud.
Now fortunately, that
is actually false.
And Anthos actually shows why
because the beauty of Anthos
is that it doesn't
try to do too much.
It standardizes the things
that should not be different,
the things that aren't
necessarily special,
let's say, how do you
actually release a binary,
how do you configure something,
how do you define a load
balancer, how do you distribute
certificates to your services.
These are all things you
have to do every day.
And they should not be
different between the clouds.
And so Anthos says, learn
it once with Anthos.
And then you can pick your
cloud or multiple clouds
or stay on premise.
And you don't have to
learn that task again.
So for all the tasks and
practices and workflows
that Anthos covers, you really
have just one team, one time
where you have to learn it.
And then you can still
take the advantage
of the uniqueness
of each environment
without having to relearn
all the basics again.
So fortunately, I think,
this is a false trade-off.
And, I think, you really want
to pick a platform that does not
lock you in for
the next 20 years
into one way of doing things.
So in my view, that's an
easy answer, pure win.
Go with multi cloud, or
be ready for multi cloud
and have the option,
because who knows
what's going to happen
in the next 10, 20 years.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah,
so it sounds like--
this was my understanding,
that multi cloud
has a lot of advantages,
flexibility, being
able to do things on the
right timeline for your team,
being able to use cloud-specific
features that you need.
But Anthos is kind of
the secret sauce here
in that it takes away a
lot of the disadvantages
about having to learn
multiple clouds, about having
to have a team trained
on multiple clouds.
And that's--
URS HOLZLE: Exactly said.
AJA HAMMERLY: --awesome.
I know that I've had to make
a decision about on prem
or cloud or both.
And both was always
scary just because of
the sheer information overload
that we had to keep track of.
I'm glad Anthos exists now.
We didn't have it back then.
So now we got a
question from Twitter.
According to you, what are the
missing pieces of cloud today?
URS HOLZLE: I'd say lots.
And actually let me put it
in a slightly different way.
I think, if we put ourselves
in our mind into 2025
and we look back on 2020
and the cloud of 2020,
I think, we'll be
embarrassed that we liked it
and that we thought it was good
because it will seem incredibly
primitive because even
though cloud is 10 years old,
it actually still is
in its early stages.
So I often compare it
to kind of mobile phones
after the first 10, 15 years.
It was sort of Nokia
and BlackBerry, right?
It wasn't Android and iOS.
And so the Android and iOS
of cloud is still coming.
And one of the
things that really
made that explosion
of functionality
in the mobile space, that made
you really rethink what you
expect of a mobile
phone, that made
you look back on your
feature phone and kind of
be surprised that
you ever liked it,
was the fact that there
were software platforms,
a set of APIs that
were auto update
and that allow you to roll
out your service to anyone
on that platform and not
have a ton of friction
from version matrix
and sort of anything.
And so that's one of the things
that I think really today
is missing in a cloud.
If you're on a single
cloud, then things are fine.
In a sense, they're consistent.
But be aware if you ever see
the need to either remain
on premise or use
another cloud because it
is an awesome service because
you're just completely starting
from scratch.
And I think five years from
now, you'll just say, wow,
I cannot believe that this
was missing back then.
It's kind of like saying,
what there were phones
without an app store on it?
That is really hard to believe.
You mean a phone that
was there to make calls?
That's really all it did?
It's hard for us to
think about today.
So, I think, I predict
that in 2025 we'll
really be in that point where
we kind of are embarrassed
about the cloud of 2020
because from the developers
perspective, from the
security perspective,
from the operations
perspective, and really
from the portability
perspective, today's cloud
and, actually, today's
cloud world really
isn't a great world.
And we want to change that.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
And the phone analogy
was super helpful.
I know that I
explained to my nieces
a couple months ago that
my first BlackBerry only
had the game Snake.
And they were horrified,
horrified that I didn't
have an app store to use.
So I'm curious what
that's going to look like.
It's going to be amazing
for the cloud world
to have that big of a
transformation and so quickly.
So let's take another
question from Midori.
Actually, this question's
from a developer community.
And this one's close to
my heart as a manager.
How do you effectively manage
high-performing technical
teams?
My team is awesome,
and any tips you
can give for the managers
in the audience about how we
can do better would be great.
URS HOLZLE: Wow.
OK.
That's a complicated
question, again.
So there's no simple answer.
I think, the one thing I
would always mention first
that people really
underappreciate is hiring,
because if you hire the
right people, then A, it's
going to make a bigger
difference than anything
else you do, and B,
management actually
becomes much easier because
you have great people who
are doing a great job.
And they need your support.
But they don't really need
your sort of corrective action
all the time.
And let me just double down
on the importance of hiring.
If you think about it, suppose
that you're at your company
and suppose you spend
a full 10% of your time
for an entire year--
so 10% every single week
you spend on hiring.
You've interviewed people.
You're trying to recruit
people, whatever.
And suppose for all that effort
you find just one person,
a single person in that year,
who is as good as you are,
I would argue that with
that 10% of your time
you have doubled your
productivity to the company.
And there's nothing else you
can do in 10% of your time
that doubles your impact.
There's really nothing else.
You cannot work harder.
You can't make better tools.
It just does not give
you a factor of 10.
So hiring really, I think,
is the key to management.
And I think if you
pay attention to it,
if you do that well, then the
rest follows much more easily.
AJA HAMMERLY: Awesome.
That's a really
insightful answer.
And I'll have to think
a bit more about that.
So let's take a more nerdy
question from Midori.
Operational frictions
often times leads
to learning opportunities.
Eliminating friction equals
eliminating opportunities
for people to learn.
I think what this
question is saying, is
that when stuff goes wrong
and your pager goes off,
it is just another
learning opportunity.
Is that always good?
URS HOLZLE: That is right.
So, I mean, there's
a good observation
that I separated in two ways.
One is, in the average company,
there is so much productive
learning, learning that
you want to do because you
get advantages from it.
And it's sort of pure upside.
You learn about containers
about CI/CD or whatever.
In the average
company they're so
much in need of
that that you really
want to focus on that kind
of learning, versus learning
from your mistakes, so to
speak, or from outages.
Now, the second part
is that, actually, it
is very important to
learn from your outages
or to learn from your mistakes.
So in the case of
outages, postmortems,
and especially
blameless postmortems,
they're focusing
on what went wrong
and how do we prevent
that from happening,
not who made a mistake.
So blameless postmortems and
learning from mistakes, again,
like maybe a postmortem
for something
in your project or a
technical decision,
that's really when
the learning happens.
So I agree with you
that the best way
to summarize that is let
no crisis go to waste.
A crisis is a huge
opportunity to actually change
how you're doing things
and avoid the next crisis.
So I'm definitely a big fan.
But I think if that becomes the
dominant form of your learning,
then you're in a
problematic spot.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
No, you don't want everything
to be on fire all the time.
And I'm really
glad you mentioned
blameless postmortems.
More than anything I've
learned in my five years
at Google, learning about the
blameless postmortem culture
and how you can learn as a team
and do better as a team has
done wonders, not
only for my work life,
but also for my personal
life and dealing
with stuff that goes sideways
at home, especially right now.
So yeah, that's great.
So now a question from Twitter.
Who are your inspirations
when it comes to tech?
Who do you look up to?
URS HOLZLE: Boy, I don't want
to name my favorite children, so
to speak.
But I think what
I admire and what
inspires me is when there are
things that in retrospect seem
obvious, but nobody thought
of them for 10 years.
So if someone finds
something that five,
even two years from now, if
someone hears about is like,
yeah, that seems pretty obvious
that it's done this way,
but it took 10 years,
20 years to find that.
That to me is the most
amazing thing and the thing
I admire most in people.
So it's really
often the simplicity
that actually makes
something awesome,
versus something
incredibly complicated.
That sometimes is unavoidable.
But really what I admire are
things that seem obvious,
but until they became
obvious they weren't obvious.
AJA HAMMERLY: All right.
That makes sense.
And that's definitely
been my experience.
I got some advice
early on in my career
that you should always be
cautious of the person who
asks the seemingly dumb question
because they've likely seen how
simpler your solution could be.
So that's great.
So our next question is
from, I believe, Midori,
and it is kind of long.
So I'm going to read it.
But then I'm going to try
to summarize it a bit.
So the question
says, I'm worried
that the Cloud Run/kNative
for scale to zero
is leaving customers with
cascading long startup latency
issues as they move to
micro services, which
get paged or swapped
out while not in use.
Can you endorse a "scale
to one alternative,"
please, to support always
having an instance ready?
So this, actually, seems
slightly like a feature request
less than a question.
But it does bring up an
interesting question about,
how do you prioritize the
advantages of something
like scale to zero and
adopting a micro services
architecture over the fact
that there are some downsides?
Scale to zero has
startup latency issues.
How would you address that
if you were trying work
with a team that was
migrating to a micro services
architecture on, say, kNative?
URS HOLZLE: Great question.
So first of all, not my job
to endorse something or not.
I'm not a sports star that
gets paid for product placement
so to speak.
So I would actually answer
it slightly differently.
And it's not the job of
the provider to pick.
It's really the job of
each of the teams to pick.
And I always say, engineering
is the art of the compromise,
because if there was a
dominant, best answer, then
it would be pretty
boring and pretty easy
because everyone does
that, end of story.
And so it's really
about trade-offs.
And the trade-offs differ by
industry, by customer, by team
even.
And so in this particular
case, the nice thing
about scale to zero is zero
cost when you don't use it.
And so for some things that's
a really great solution.
Suppose you have
an internal app,
and it gives you the
W-2 that you download.
For those of you
international, W-2
is your tax form, your
end-of-year tax form.
Well, probably 360 days of the
year, nobody uses that app.
And you don't want
to pay for it.
So scale to zero is great.
And if the first person
has to wait a second or two
to download their
tax return, that's
fine, because once
tax season is there,
the application is probably hot.
On the other hand, as
you say, that actually
if you have a different
app that maybe
is idle for a little
while but then is
being used again and then idle
for a while and used again,
we kind of don't want to
introduce multi-second startup
latency for the poor person
who is the next person
to use your app.
So to me that's a trade-off.
I think it's a good
feature request.
You can actually
easily implement
that yourself by just
having a little--
actually you should probably
do end-to-end monitoring
of your key workflows.
And so if you did that
frequently enough,
you will keep your functions
warm and your startup latencies
low.
But to me, again,
it really comes down
to engineering and figuring
out [INAUDIBLE] the business
value, what problem
are we solving
and what are the
options that we have
and among these, which
one is the least worst,
sometimes called the best.
Usually the best isn't
actually flawless.
Everything has some problems.
So that, I think, is a great
place to end and really say,
I agree with you.
It should be, actually, a simple
configuration option, never
going down to zero.
I value latency over
totally minimal cost.
I don't think we
have that in kNative.
But if you know how to
file a feature request,
I think it's a
good one, actually.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
So it seems like the
answer is, like the answer
to almost every technical
question, is it depends.
It depends on your use case.
And it depends on what the right
choice for your engineering
team is, which might have to
do with the people you have
and the time they have
and the skills they have.
So that's amazing.
And I know that there's--
I don't know that
we don't have it.
I should know the
answer to this.
And I don't.
And I'm slightly
embarrassed about that.
So next question from Twitter--
actually, no, this next
question is from Midori.
Ooh, this is a good one.
What are some of your favorite
failed Google infrastructure
projects that were
such cool ideas
that they had to be tried
irrespective of the outcome?
URS HOLZLE: Well, first of
all, if you knew the outcome,
you wouldn't have tried it,
probably even if it was cool.
So, I mean, failures happen
because you don't quite
predict what's going to happen.
I think, on an
infrastructure side,
one of the things I would
want to mention actually
goes back 15 years ago.
So 15 years ago we got into
building our own data centers
because we were sort of running
out of rented data centers.
And we could see the time that
the rents would really go up
because up until that point--
for those of you who were
there, the internet bubble
burst in 2000.
And there was just
boatloads of data center
space that was empty
and was cheap to rent.
And so as we were
growing, we were really
growing into a
lot of empty space
that went through bankruptcies
and therefore was really cheap.
So as we were seeing
that coming to an end,
we thought about,
well, what do we
do to make our own data centers?
And, obviously, they've
got to be cheap.
And not just cheap to build,
but also cheap to operate.
And one of the things we
noticed was that, almost half
of our data center
bill was energy, power.
And what was actually
really offensive
is that a significant fraction
of that, again, about half
of that was completely wasted.
It wasn't actually energy to
power your CPU and your memory.
It just went elsewhere.
The building cooling,
your power supply,
all kinds of places that you
didn't really care about.
And so we started to build
more efficient data centers.
And our first
approach was what's
called a containerized
data center.
And so, basically, the idea
was instead of building really
a building and trying to cool
the building, why don't you
just cool the servers?
And by the way,
put those servers
into literally a
shipping container.
And then inside that
shipping container,
it's very easy to
control the airflow.
And then you have sort
of a modular unit,
where you can deploy,
let's say, space
for 1,000 servers at a time.
And you just put
this in a warehouse.
And you can go to YouTube.
Look for container data center
Google, something like that.
We have some videos
way back from 2005.
And it turned out to be a
great idea in some aspects.
It was actually very efficient.
And it was pretty cheap.
But it turned out those
containers were actually
sort of unwieldy.
You needed large
buildings to kind
of maneuver them in
and out and a crane
and all kinds of things.
And then, also, it would
really constrain your space.
The shipping containers
is a fixed form factor.
You have to kind of
cram in your servers.
And they were not really
deep enough, et cetera.
And so really that was a
big failure in some extent.
We did it once and never again.
But at the same
time, it was really
one of these classic
opportunities
where it was fairly
fast to fail.
And we learned a ton.
And we actually used a
lot of those principles
in our next data center,
which we actually
called containerless,
or the nontainer--
like the non container--
where we could preserve a
lot of the cooling efficiency
and the cheapness but,
basically, put all of that
into the row of the server,
versus an entire enclosure.
And so today, even
today, what you
see sort of in each server row
actually looks pretty low tech.
If you go look up some
pictures or some videos,
it's just kind of metal.
And the metal is really sort of
a mini container for a server
that's in each slot.
But we don't have
the container around.
So that is probably one
of my favorite failures,
because it definitely
was a failure.
That was not, in the
end, a great idea.
But it led to, actually,
rapid innovation
in the data center
space and actually
was a step that although
you partially regret it,
it was a failure
that really paid off.
AJA HAMMERLY: Yeah.
I remember reading a lot about
Google's containerized data
centers.
And those were cool.
And I'm glad that lots
of cool technology
came out of it too
and new approaches.
URS HOLZLE: They
were actually hot.
They were actually
hot, 27 degrees.
AJA HAMMERLY: They were hot.
Yes, of course.
URS HOLZLE: 80 degrees
Fahrenheit, yes.
AJA HAMMERLY: Google's
all about containers.
So last question.
What will the next game
changer within cloud be?
Is it going to be
quantum computing?
URS HOLZLE: Probably
not the next one,
because quantum computing
is one of these things
that when it works,
it will be awesome.
But at the same time, there's
some really pretty big problems
left.
And though we're kind
of making progress,
it's always kind of
five years plus out.
And when someone tells
you it's five years out,
they really kind of mean, I'm
not sure how long it will take.
So I hope that there's
innovation in cloud before.
I do think that one
of the game changers
really is to change cloud away
from thinking about it as three
different clouds, and you have
to choose one of the three.
I think that really is going
to be outdated very soon.
It's going to kind
feel like, for those
that were around in 1995--
in 1995, it was
sort of-- servers
were new, away from mini
computers and mainframes.
PC's were new, x86.
Unix was new.
And Java was new.
The enterprise
really kind of needed
to change how it did computing.
And back then everyone
sort of obsessed about,
should I pick DEC
or Sun or Compaq.
Which vendor do I pick,
which hardware vendor?
But it was not just
the hardware vendor.
Because if you pick
one hardware vendor,
you've got a different OS.
And you've got a
different compiler.
different database.
And you pick the whole thing.
Everything was different.
And that's kind of the mode
that we're in today with cloud.
If you pick one
cloud, then the way
you start the
container or the way
you start a VM is different
from somewhere else.
But that actually kind
of doesn't make sense.
It's just starting a container.
And in the end sort of
everyone does the same thing.
So why isn't it the same?
So in the server
space back in '95,
it took about 10 years
for that to play out.
And 10 years later
people realized
that it's not about
picking the server vendor.
That's important for
hardware reasons.
But it's not a choice
that you have to stick
with for the next 20 years.
The choice that
matters, back in 2005,
was Linux versus Windows Server.
If you picked one of
them, that stayed with you
for a decade or two.
And in this particular
case, if you picked Linux
and if you picked open
source, you really
picked a growing
ecosystem around it.
And you could pick
anything below and pretty
much anything above.
And so that's what
we're really trying
to do to the cloud space
with Anthos to say,
Anthos is kind of
like [INAUDIBLE]..
It's not the same
because it's managed.
So you do get open source.
But you don't have to worry
about the updates and security
patches, et cetera.
But it actually
has the same sort
of horizontal property,
where now you don't really
care about what's below.
You may still care about it for
performance or cost reasons.
But it's not a
stack that's below.
It's kind of more like hosting.
And an above it's
pretty much anything.
So any service you
want to consume,
any development practice you
want to use, you can do that.
And that's independent
of the environment.
So that, to me, really
actually is a game changer,
because it moves the
whole thinking away
from sort of the
AOL model, pick AOL,
and then everything is the
AOL way, to the internet model
where you pick open standards.
And then you can mix and
match and really adopt
the things that work best
for you and do something.
If you picked Linux 20 years
ago, it's still with you.
And it's still a great choice
because all the other things
around it--
you could change your
opinion, your choice.
And so Linux didn't
constrain you in that way.
And that's really, I think,
what the big revolution in cloud
will be, that Anthos
together with Kubernetes
gives you that same portability
and that same learning at once.
And then just do it
for the next 10 years.
That really changes how
people look at cloud.
AJA HAMMERLY: That
makes a lot of sense.
And it totally makes sense that
moving toward open standards
that work anywhere is going
to give people the flexibility
to do what's right for
them, which is awesome.
So I want to thank you
so much for chatting
with us today and sharing
your thoughts and insights.
And I want to thank our
audience for joining us
virtually and submitting
some really insightful,
thoughtful questions.
This Q&A isn't the only thing we
have going on this week at Next
on Air, though.
There's lots going on.
And I want to
encourage all of you
to check out some
of the other things.
So if you want to dig
in and learn more,
we have a couple different
options available.
First of all, you can
book a one-on-one session
with a Googler, chat or
video chat for 15 minutes,
talk more about the products
or specific problems you have
or find out more about
what learning content is
right for you.
To do that, you
can book a session
at the URL on your
screen right now.
I also want to do a
shout-out for my team.
We're hosting a live developer
talk session this Friday.
Two folks I work
with, Dave and Ian,
are going to be hosting that.
And if you want to
learn more about that,
the URL is the second one on
your screen, talks-by-devrel.
And I know a lot of folks--
I'm definitely like this.
And I know a lot of
our developer audience
just wants to dig in and
get their hands dirty.
They don't want
to hear about it.
They don't want to read about.
They just want to try it.
And if that's you-- it
doesn't have to be all of you,
but there's probably a few
of you in the audience--
I can recommend
our Learning Hub.
Go to the next Learning Hub.
And go do a code lab.
Do some tutorials.
Just get your hands dirty.
Try it.
See if it's going
to work for you.
That's the fastest way
often to fail fast and learn
if something is the right match
for the problems you currently
have.
And check out the rest of our
content as part of Next on Air.
We've done a lot of work to
create super cool talks, demos,
and other ways that you can
learn about what's happening,
what's new, and what models
are working for people
who use Google Cloud.
I've been really proud
of the work that's
happened in the talks
that have been created.
So to finally close out,
I want to thank Urs again.
And I want to thank all
of you for showing up.
This was fantastic.
And I learned a lot.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you too, Aja.
And thanks, everyone,
for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]